we've been together for a while and um
over the course of the last maybe year
um he revealed that he's in a lot of
credit card debt um about
$58,000 worth um so in February of this
year I actually took out a home equity
loan um at prime rate so what is that
8.5 I think so he cut up his credit
cards and we put all of his money um we
Consolidated all of his credit card debt
into a helck and he's been making steady
payments since then to me to pay on that
Lord Jesus okay so um he commits to
about $1,000 a month to paying that off
and um we're predicting about a four and
a half year to fiveyear payoff of all
that no no no what do you make I only
make $60,000 a year and he makes 120
okay so you make $180,000 you have
$58,000 in debt we are not waiting six
freaking years you're doing this next
year